all right Mark
yeah Mark uh where'd you grow up where
are you from originally oh San Diego
Valley
thank you everybody
tell me about your your family growing
up you had both your parents um
I didn't mean my dad till I was like 12
so it was just me my mom
um
it was [__] um
constant uh babysitting
constant babysitting of who of my mom
she was an alcoholic crackhead
catching the bar every night it's like I
had different different Uncle every time
I went to school
I guess you could say everybody [__]
there was there was no childhood
you said you had no childhood no not
really
things like for you you're were you
alone only child at that point yeah
everybody else already old enough to
move thrown away as hell
what kind of stuff was going on at home
when your mom was
my mom's my mom's boyfriend used to last
me for a few years
um
that went on for a few years until
[__] um
I felt I don't even remember how it
transpired
um but how old were you
I was still in diapers I was selling
diapers
oh no [__] all I can remember is me
being taken away putting foster home and
then um
giving back if you sometime later so
um
[__]
it's just [__] there's a shot down
there
just [__] went upset after another
how far are you in school
oh I finished I finished high school
yeah I got my high school diploma
you grew up here in L.A yeah
yeah in prison jail
oh
how long you been on the streets
since 2002
2002 how old do you know
I'm actually 40.
it's gonna be my birthday if um like a
few days
so
uh yeah
drugs are part of your life now
drugs are basically [__] you might want
to say they are in my life at this point
but but
um
I'm working on that man I'm working on
that what is your drug crystal meth
crystal meth and Fenton on Alpha
um
yes that's it
where do you stay at night everywhere
just wherever yeah everywhere I can
how do you make money
so I gotta go suck a dick suck a dick
like go do this or that I don't care
whatever I can do that makes money [__]
it
I don't really really doesn't have a
problem for me
do you have no one to go to now no
family
as of today no no [__] no as I'm staying
now I know
I never thought somebody would do what
they just did
what's up
allow me to come to him
would allow me to come to them for help
and then
have me
treated the way it [__]
crazy it's crazy
never I've never had it happen
but I can tell you this I don't have it
I don't have nobody left
as of today nobody left
emotionally what do you go through
emotionally [__] man sometimes I feel
like picking people off when I want from
top of a [__] type of building and
[__]
um
yeah I'm a lot of anger I have a lot of
anger I have a lot of [__] um
not a [__] hate sadness whatever
[__] wanna call me but um [__]
um is that shingles that I see on your
neck yes yes yes yes and they [__]
hurt so bad
uh I'm trying to [__] um
I'm trying to [__] take my mind off
them
in different ways in seconds
honestly the only thing that helps is
the Vietnam but is it just on your neck
and chest
like here
and
here in my back on my back the back is
my my back is what is the most but I
can't see in the [__] game no no I
can't see him get no houses for myself
like like what the what the [__] going
on here like that
no matter what I'm trying no matter what
I'm trying to do
it doesn't seem that I'm being able to
get the right
shingles is painful or itches or what no
it's painful it's [__] painful man
this [__] is painful like a muffler it
feels like it feels like they're on fire
but yet they hurt so bad
you can see if I can
I don't give a [__]
that [__] hurts bad dad and your neck is
just spent huh your neck is just as bad
oh
dear friends no
I don't
I don't want him either I don't wanna I
don't need them
I don't want any friends
I don't need them
they just want they just want from you
they'll take from you and they'll leave
you be and that's it
what's your biggest fear no hurting them
hurting them
you know what I mean
I would never never thought of doing the
things that they've done to me
to anybody else
you know
but if I could sit here and picture
myself picking them off from the top of
a building one by one as they're walking
down the street
I I'm pretty sure I could [__] just
have English endless thoughts but I
don't I don't
I don't I don't I don't [__] I'm
saying
I don't
move on that you mean
I just I
have anger and I [__]
that's what I think about and [__]
that's about it I don't make no action
of it or whatever the [__] it is but
[__] I mean [__] this [__] if they only
knew you mean
but yeah in a senate
and your father [__] him I don't know I
really don't I never met him I barely
met him like one time
and I was buried briefly I was like well
like 11 12 12 11 or 12.
that was very briefly
and your mom is aware now they're both
dead they're both dead yep
all my mom's family is dead except for
my grandma she seemed to outlive all her
kids
oh she's the worst one off she's the
best alcoholic [__] there is [__]
so old and she she outlived her kids
that's crazy
she had your life to live all over again
what would you have done differently
let the drugs Mom I'm sorry left the
drugs alone left the drugs alone yeah I
left them low I wouldn't touch them I
wouldn't stop I would never even give
him a thought
because if
I come down to a bro like this [__]
can't do it I don't want to do it
you think there's a better chance of you
getting clean or
of getting into deeper trouble at a
certain time when the time is right I
guess
um
everything everything happens in its own
time you know so
um I've learned that not to push stuff
not just not to
not to push anything
and when it does oh no
do you feel like you're cursed
[__] yeah every day every [__] day
dude
every day of my life
every day
every day I gotta meet somebody new
every day I gotta talk to somebody new
every time I got a [__] dismiss a
friend yeah
yeah
of course I am
and emotionally you go through what
mostly depression
yeah of course
yep
that sucks
it sucks when you don't have any talk to
you about it like to
do what trying to [__] Vince chew up
to anyone about any of that [__]
it's hard
have you seen a doctor about your
shingles yeah I'm taking medication but
that's it something that's all they gave
me here
is this helping at all
yeah but um when it comes to the pain
[__] no
laughs
do you still have hope yeah of course
every day every day every day I'm every
day I hope I hope every day
every day I tell myself it's gonna get
better because I know it is I know it
may not happen now but I know it's gonna
get better
I just have to [__] be patient
what's your greatest strength
that I can [__] sit here and cut your
face off and not give a [__] you know
what I mean not really give the second
thought about [__] what your name was
or like why I did it or [__] who who
you [__] knew or what you were
um
that part that part is like one of my
strongest Parts because
it keeps me from being um
cases for letting people in you're not
even close so
that's uh that's the strongest part I
have
do you have any good memories of your
childhood no no I don't [__] no I don't
know Mark what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life what I've learned
um
I mean
got a choice
either you're gonna keep going
to eat you up
I don't choose a lady up again yeah
all right Mark thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you I wish you
lots of luck out here yeah sure